- I’m not actually that nervous.
What?
- So, I’m gonna be cutting
Jennifer’s hair today.
- If I went like, snip,
right there a lot would...
See, already I can see her
getting really angry at me.
- You better not do that.
- She doesn’t want me to do that.
- [Steven] New Girl look.
New cut, new girl, new life.
- [Tyler] Safiya has a lot of hair.
We’re gonna bring it back.
- I think you’re gonna be surprised.
- Hopefully, but I do have
a hair appointment scheduled
just in case.
(intense music)
- I feel like I’m constructing
an Ikea set right now.
(bleep)
- That means I’m gonna look awful.
- I feel like I’m on
Project Runway right now.
- They don’t cut their
hair on Project Runway.
- [Tyler] Okay, nevermind.
- That felt like a lot.
(whimpering)
- [Steven] Not good?
- It’s so short!
- If you ponytail it and
cut it, I’ll kill you.
(laughing)
- Okay.
- What is that face you just made?
(giggling)
- Wait, no.
Babe it’s gonna look good,
don’t worry about it.
- [Jennifer] I don’t understand...
(giggling)
The method that you’re using.
- I’m sorry, I never went
to haircutting school.
- I would advise you to look at my front
and make sure the two sides are the same.
Like, the same length.
- [Tyler] Okay.
- And there’s no awkward strands
like the ones that I’m
feeling and pulling at—
- [Tyler] Okay, okay!
- Should I do it all in one?
Like, all in one swoop?
- [Jennifer] Sure.
- Is that the right way to do it?
(giggling)
- No!
- [Steven] Just like that?
- [Jennifer] You go below, yeah.
- [Steven] Like this?
- [Jennifer] Sure.
(bleep)
- Hang on one second.
- [Steven] I just cut myself, there.
- Oh my god, wait, we’re good!
We’re good! It’s so short!
- [Steven] Wait, stop.
- [Jennifer] Do I look
horrible?
- [Steven] No, I think it
looks, I think it looks cute.
- [Safiya] Yeah?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- Is it good?
Maybe?
- I think this is pretty good!
- Okay?
- It may not be even everywhere.
(laughter)
- Alright...
(laughing)
Oh my god!
- No good?
- It doesn’t look bad, actually.
It looks pretty good.
- [Tyler] Right?
- It doesn’t look like
Jennifer Aniston at all.
- I look like one of
those scary monster dolls
that you find at Toys R Us.
- It looks like a trim.
- [Tyler] Yeah!
- [Safiya] Kind of.
- Your hair’s just a little shorter.
- I think it’s a good
look, I like the bang look.
It’s a banging set of bangs
you got going on there.
- See, cause look at this.
It’s like in, and down.
That’s really the problem.
(playful music)
- I thought it would be worse, I mean...
I can live with it.
- See? Not terrible.
That’s all I was going for.
- You look cute.
- I know.
- Yikes.
(smooches)
- You need trust for something like this.
Um, I definitely have a
little bit more respect
for hairstylists.
- Me too.
- [Steven] She’s still pretty cute.
- [Jennifer] Thanks.
- [Steven] You’ve got hair
all over you by the way.